this course is your ultimate guide to
mastering the world of role-based
authentication in nextjs using OJs this
course provides you with the most
up-to-date coverage on the latest
features of nextjs guiding you through
the implementation of authentication on
both server rendered and client rendered
pages and it shows you how to leverage
out of the box oof providers like Google
and GitHub as well as creating your own
custom authentication provider using
mongodb Jacob lower teaches this course
he is a popular instructor on topics
related to nextjs let's start learning
what is up freec code Camp it's Jake
lower again here to show you another
nextjs video in this one we're going to
cover authentication we're going to show
you simply how to put authentication in
your nextjs application so we're going
to spin up a blank application and then
we're going to spin up authentication
immediately in that application we're
going to use buil-in oo providers of OJs
like GitHub and Google that we all use
and then in the end we're also going to
show you how to roll your own login
system using mongod DB we're going to
also investigate ro-based authentication
as well so you'll be able to give admin
roles and different things like that
we're going to cover how you can secure
server side Pages as well as client side
pages to cover all your authentication
needs in this one video if you like
these type of videos they come out on my
Channel first Clarity coders check that
out as well as our website Clarity
coders dcom let's not waste any more
time and Jump Right In All right so here
we are in Visual Studio code I'm not
going to do a lot of setup you can watch
one of my other videos for exactly how
you can get some of this installed make
sure you have no JS have some
familiarization with nextjs projects
would probably be helpful I also used a
couple extensions that'll show really
quick this es7 plus react redex code
Snippets it's very useful I'm going to
use it a lot in this video so you can go
ahead and download that prettier as well
for formatting code uh you can see the
others in here that I use feel free to
freeze and install those if you would
like let's go ahead and spin up this
project so I'm going to open up a new
terminal you can code along with me I
really feel that's the best way to learn
so that's how I like to do these
tutorials and let's do MPX create next
app we'll go ahead and click yes to
proceed we can call this project
our next off tutorial or whatever you
would like I'm not going to use
typescript so you're you're able to
convert this typescript if you'd like
I'm going to select no I would recommend
if you're following along to do the same
I'm going to use eslint Tailwind yes
Source directory I'm going to say no app
router yes and would you like to
customize the default Alias no so we'll
let that spin up this project and then
we have should have some boiler plate to
work with great so now we have our
project spun up you can see where it
created the project file I want you to
go ahead and open up that folder and
then we'll continue on from there so if
you're using visual studio code you can
do file open folder and then pop open
that window and you should end up with
something that looks like this so now we
have our project folder open I'm going
to do one more install here so I've
opened another terminal let's go ahead
and install next off CU we're obviously
going to use that so we'll do mpm I next
dash
off and then let's take a quick look at
our package.json here you can see my
exact dependencies you can copy these if
you want them to work perfectly so you
can see I'm using
13.5.3 any version above this should be
okay um if not try installing with this
exact version and that could help uh
same with
nexo now let's get to cutting down this
app a little bit let's expand the app
folder let's go out to our Global
CSS let's delete all of this in here and
then I will save we only really are
going to use two things let's go ahead
and set it up just so we're done with it
so we'll do at layer base bam we can do
an H1 which we're going to use just to
make things look a little more like
we're used to we'll do font bold text-
3XL just for the correct text sizing
just so it looks a little better then
we'll also do an a tag we'll do at apply
let's do
underline and
font bold and again this will just help
kind of visualize what we're doing as
we're doing it nothing too crazy here
and then let's open up our page I'm
going to go ahead and contr a and just
delete all this out and this is where my
extension is going to come in handy I'm
going to do rafc a lot that's that code
snippet one that I showed you and then
control shift L and this can just be our
homepage so I'm going to change all
these at once nothing crazy here and we
can close that close our Styles we
should be actually done with those
honestly let's rename this to page. jsx
just so it's consistent there and then
let's create all of our other Pages for
our application I'm going to Showcase
some different types of authentication
on some different types of pages so
that's why we have multiple so let's do
new folder here we are going to have a
member page so this is a private
protected page for only people who have
signed up so we'll do a member folder
and then a new file in here that we'll
call page. jsx and then on that member
page we can do
rafc just like before control shift L
and we will do member and then let's add
in H1 tags
here and this is going to be our
member server session so remember if we
don't add Ed client up above our import
statements it's going to render the p p
on the server side so this is going to
show you how we can protect a server
side page on our
application so let's create a new folder
and then as you probably could guess
we're going to do a client member page
so let's create a client member folder
and then I'm just going to copy this
page paste it in here we'll close this
one out to make sure that we're using
the right one and then you'll see this
is our client member page so let's let's
use a member cant session for this one
and then of course to ensure that this
is rendered on the client side we have
to explicitly tell that we want to use
the client side so I'm showing you this
this shouldn't be your default you
should never just default to rendering a
page on the client side but there are
certainly occasions where you'll have to
so this is our example of that we are
also going to have a denied page so most
of the time we're going to Route people
to a login if they have't authenticated
but what if they have authenticated and
they just don't have permissions in
role-based
authentication in that scenario we're
going to direct them towards a denied
page so let's just create another folder
at that application Level for denied
we'll create a new page. jsx inside of
this here we can do rafc
contrl shift L we'll do
denied we'll use H1 tags for
this again just because make it look a
little better there and then we will do
a tiny bit of styling now this is this
is a stretch when we're calling this
styling but let's say text-
red- 400 so this will just be a red
denied that we send people to if they
don't have the correct authentication
for our page and then let's do one other
so this is going to
be eventually our page that's protected
by roles so only an admin eventually
we'll be able to go to this page so
let's create a create user folder and
then inside of that let's create a new
file called page.
jsx and then r a
c control shift
L and we will call this create
user we'll say only
admins now this is eventually it's not
going to work like that out of the gate
but we have our structure in place I
think that's most of the pages that
we're going to need in this project as
well so we should good there let's
create another
folder so let's say new folder we're
going to use uh open parentheses and
then
components o
compon like
that and then new file let's do our
navigation. jsx I'm going to use a
capital N with this this will just be
our navigation bar up top that we can
get set up now we can do our normal
rafc that all looks pretty
good now instead of here we're going to
do a little more coding this time to get
this set up and then we should be good
to go let's do a header let's also do
nav
tags so for our header let's do class
name we're not going to do we're going
to do almost no styling but BG gray 600
and then text Gray 100
should be good and then on the nav side
let's do class name is
flex justify
between items
Center width is
full let's do a px of 10 and finally a
py of four that should be
good let's close out of this terminal
window for now just so it's a little
less distracting and we'll go inside our
nav tags here so for the first div let's
just do my site and then for the second
div and our only other component in here
let's do a class name of
flex gap of
10 that should be good then we're going
to add in some links
make sure you're doing the import as
well so I'm going to tab complete here
and that should do the
import you'll see that it did import
link from next link we need an href for
this so we already created our homepage
it's at
slash we can call this
home let's copy this so we got home we
got create user member only client let's
do a public page page so we got home
then next let's do our create user
page now remember eventually this will
only
be for admins so we'll do create
user let's do our client member
page so again this should be protected
you have to be logged in you don't have
to be an
admin let's do our member
page this is almost the exact same thing
except it's rendered on the server
instead of on the client
side and then let's do a public page
which is completely
unprotected we'll do public
here that looks pretty good now we can
go ahead and go into our layout JS we're
almost ready to get into nextjs this is
the last tiny bit of setup here so let's
delete out the Google fonts we don't
care about that we don't care
about
that and then make sure you kill the
reference to the Google fonts as well
should be good and cleaned up you can
change this if you'd like we're not
worried about it here we got our HTML we
got our
body let's do a class name of
BG gray 100 so this is just the
background let's import our nav ation
let's do nav like that make sure you do
the import here so I'm going to tab
you'll see it imported our component
from above we can self close so slash
and then our greater than sign and then
let's just wrap this in a div as well
this these children here just so we can
do one other tiny bit of
formatting div this class name let's do
a margin of two on it should be good to
go okay so we did some coding we got the
structure set up we're going to work in
next off next let's open our terminal
just make sure this runs let's do mpm
runev we got no errors that is a good
sign let's check it out in the browser
we're going going to go to local hoston
3000 dang look at us web development who
says I can't style applications this is
beautiful you can tell what page we're
on by the our little reference that page
so you see we have a create user client
member
member and our public page we didn't do
anything with the public page let's fix
that up and let's just check real quick
we should have a denied one as well yes
so we are all good there let's make a
quick change to the public page just so
we can reference that we're on it oh I
didn't route to it at all did I yeah not
found I didn't create the public page so
new full folder let's do public inside
here new file page. jsx
rafc control shift L let's do
public delete that
out put our H1
tags just like we did for the others I
didn't for the create user because we're
going to do something else that we're
actually going to create users towards
the latter half of this okay so we
should be all good we got all of our
pages we don't have any authentication
set up whatsoever but we're going to get
into that next let's go ahead and jump
into that so we know we need to create
an API folder and that's going to be
what next off looks for so let's create
API folder inside of that we need to
create another folder called op inside
of that so I'm right clicking on off
here new folder I'm going to use square
brackets and then inside of those square
brackets I'm going to do dot dot dot
three dots next off and then inside of
this you'll typically see one of two
things so you might have a route well
you need to have a route. JS and you
might have an options. JS which are
going to lay out the options of your
project so we're going to follow that
format so let's create a new file and
let's do route.
JS and then in the same name folder so
inside that next off off folder we're
going to create options. JS as well
let's start with the route. JS just so
we don't forget it is the simpler of the
two because we're going to import in our
options so let's do an import I'm going
to close out my terminal just because
it's distracting let's do import next
off tab auto complete you can see I'm
getting next Das off SL next I don't
know that I want that let's delete out
the slash next let's just do next off
from next
o and let's do import options plural
from SL options so this is going to
import our file from our other directory
Zu const Handler equals next
off options and then we're going to
export Handler as get
Handler as
post now this is straight from the next
off or aujs documentation so we're just
setting this up basically how they have
it set
up I'm going to close out of these other
tabs I actually think we're done with
route. js2 I'll close out of that and
now we can set up our options here so
this options file is going to be where
you import and set up how you want
people to be able to authenticate with
your application so we're going to start
with two and these are builtin providers
by next off so we don't have to do or we
don't have to do very much setup with
them so let's do
import get Hub
Provider
from next-
off/ providers
slash
GitHub
let's copy that paste it
below let's do this is a capital
G Google
provider and we're going to do the same
thing except at the end it's going to be
Google as well then let's do export
const options
equals
providers colon square brackets so here
we can add an array of the different
providers that we'd like to use in our
case we want to use the
GitHub
provider parentheses curly
brackets and then inside of here we can
set up anything that we would like for
our GitHub so we can add extra roles we
can add extra features or we can leave
it as plain Jane as we want and just
ship it that way but we are going to
show you how you can add rolls as well
while we're doing this so let's go ahead
and add in a profile and we're going to
be passed a profile back for we're going
to get a profile back then we can do
curly brackets and inside of here we can
add extra logic so let's say
console.log let's log out our profile
let's make sure we know what it is too
so we can say
profile
of
GitHub and then we can log that now we
want to add extra stuff to our session
so one thing that we can do we can add
extra logic that allows us to give
specific roles to specific users now my
user that we can use in this that I'm
going to sign up for the application
with is Jake Clarity coders
docomo role is going to be GitHub user
so let's do let user roll
equal
GitHub user so this is going to be the
role for everybody but me but I'm going
to say
if my profile exists and it has an email
and that email is equal to
Jake Clarity coders dcom and you want to
use your email here an email that you
can actually test this at your current
location to give yourself admin rights
to to our test application so Sub in
your email here so if our email equals
Jake at Clarity go.com or whatever your
email is then our user Ro is going to be
upgraded to admin then we will return
our new profile we're going to do dot
dot dot so everything that was in the
profile before we want to still be in
the profile however we want a new role
of our user role and that's it you see I
controlled s there it got the formatting
all right thank you prettier this is our
GitHub provider so let's copy this so
we're copying
everything on the GitHub provider and
let's paste it
below and then let's set up our
Google provider so for this one we're
going to handle things pretty close to
the same the only thing we don't want
any extra logic so let's change this and
let's say this is is our Google profile
and you don't have to log these out this
is just so you can see what's on them
and that sort of thing so we're going to
console.log that out no special roles
for this and one small change with the
Google profile we need an ID field and
the Google profile does not provide one
so let's set our ID equal to
profile. sub this is going to be the
idid that they pass back make sure to
add a comma after this as well so we
should be set up there as well now for
each of these we have to have a client
ID and a client secret that we're going
to set up with these providers so we can
utilize them in our application so on
the level of the profile here after that
profile we're going to hit enter here
and for our GitHub one we're going to
have a
client ID colon and we're going to set
it equal to process. EnV
dog
hubor ID let's copy this now these are
environmental variables that we're going
to set up that are not set up yet so
this is going to be our
client
secret and this will be GitHub unor
secret make sure to put commas after
these and then we can copy them and down
here on the Google one so we're after
the profile we're going to add these in
here except this will
be a Google
ID and a Google
secret perfect so now these are set up
that is looking good and we're going to
make one more change out of the box here
to ensure that we have our Ro available
for us in this application we're going
to set up some custom
callbacks and this will essentially add
our roll to the Token so we can utilize
it in our programs so notice I'm after
the square bracket comma I'm going to
enter some callbacks here we are going
to do
async
JWT parentheses curly brackets we're
going to get a token and we're going to
get a
user and from that we can say if we have
a
user let's say the token. roll is equal
to the US user. roll so this will allow
us to add that token add that Ro onto
our token so we can utilize it on the
server side however we also want to be
able to utilize this on the client side
as well so we will do async
session and here we can use
session and our
token and here we're going to
essentially do the same thing we're
going to
say if
we have a
session.
user let's set session. user. roll equal
to token. roll and this will allow us to
use it there then of course we need to
return our session so we have it and
then up here as I have forgotten let's
also return our
token and of course comma here awesome
awesome so now we should have this set
up so we got our providers set up we got
our sessions set up everything looks
great there now we need to set up our
provider on the provider side so let's
create a new file and this is going to
be at the base level so it should be at
the same level as your Tailwind config
or the readme or whatever let's set up a
new file let's go Dov
dolal in here we can set up our
environmental
variables so remember they're going to
look like this we want to utilize the
same verbiage here so let's do Google
ID Google secret like that and these are
going to have equals
afterwards we're also going to need a
GitHub
ID and a
GitHub secret as well so we're going to
set both of these up
now all right so now if you are logged
into your GitHub account you can go to
github.com
setting apps from here we're going to
select oo
apps and then we can
create a new oo
app we can name it whatever we would
like so we can
do next off video
tutorial
we can set up a homepage for it so we're
going to do HTTP colon localhost colon
3000 and then we also need to utilize a
callback URL so we're going to copy that
paste it down below here it's going to
be
3000i off callback SL GitHub you need to
type it exactly like I did here and then
we can register our
application now now from here we're
going to get a client ID and a client
secret ensure that you do not use mine
that won't work and make sure you don't
have anything weird any spaces or
whatever so we're going to copy this
client
ID and remember this is GitHub don't get
them confused so we're going to do our
client ID there and then let's generate
a new client secret you might have to
authenticate I'm going to copy that
secret and then paste that as well so we
now have our GitHub provider set up
that's really it it's relatively easy
and then we're going to do the same
thing on the Google side of things so
you're going to go to Google's developer
console so it's console.
developers.google.com and then from here
we can go to
credentials and we can create
credentials and we're going to do an oo
client
ID we can say web application I don't
know if it really matters we'll do
a next off video
tutorial don't miss this so we need an
authorized redirect URI let's add that
as you can guess it is HTTP col
localhost colon 3000 SL API
SLO SL
callbacks call back rather slash
gooogle API off call back Google let's
go ahead and
create so here you can see our client ID
and our client secret let's go ahead and
grab those so let's grab our client
ID
paste that
in and let's do the same with the secret
so we'll grab that and paste that in as
well awesome so we should be all set up
to authenticate with our application
with whatever user we would like however
we don't currently have any
Authentication set up on the individual
pages so we don't really have a way of
knowing if we're authenticated or not
and we also don't have a way to log into
our application yet so let's go ahead
and set that up first so inside of
get
server session down here tab complete
from next off and then we can utilize
that to see if we have an ongoing
session right now at the moment so what
we can do is right in here we can say
const session equals
await get server session and then we
need to pass in our options so you see
I'm going to autocomplete here but these
are inside our API a blah blah blah that
whole directory you can see it imported
correctly and it's mad because I'm using
an async function so I up here need to
add a sync perfect so now we should have
a session if we have a session which we
don't right now because we haven't
logged in so after the public
page let's add curly brackets and let's
check to see if we have a session so if
we have a session we want to add in a
link and we want the hre to equal and
this is going to be our log out
functionality remember if we have a
session we're logged in let's do slash
API SL off slash sign
out and I'm going to add this so I'm
going to add question mark call back
Capital
URL a capital u and then lowercase RL
equals slash so this means when we sign
out it's automatically going to send us
back to the root of our directory let's
close that link tag and we can call this
log out now we're doing conditional
rendering here so it's only going to
render this again if we have a session
so now we need to handle if we don't
have a session which is what we
currently have so let's do colon and
then let's paste this in I'll save it so
it wraps and you guys can see a little
better so if we don't have a session
then we want to be able to log in so
we're going to go to the same page we're
going to go to API
SLO sign in this time so now we should
be able to tell if we have a session
because we'll either have a log in or a
log out button we should not have both
hopefully so let's go ahead and check
this out so now back on our site so we
have our site here loaded up you'll see
we we do have a log in button we do not
have a log out button which makes sense
right because
we do not currently have a session let's
hit log in you'll see we get this nice
built in now you can customize this
that's not what we're going to cover in
this tutorial but you can customize this
but you see we got our two providers
that we're able to log in with now
remember if I log in with GitHub I am
authenticated with my Jake at Clarity
coder so that's going to be assigned in
admin the other one will be a normal
session it won't be my admin session so
let's authenticate with GitHub you're
going to have to authorize the first
time you do it and you'll get redirected
back to your application if this didn't
happen correctly double check that you
added that call back URL correctly to
GitHub and likewise when you test it
with Google the same way there you're
going to have to make sure that you have
a valid session there as well so now
you'll notice that I did log in that did
work
correctly but I still have my login
options so it's not showcasing a session
at the moment so we did have the
terminal still open you can see what our
issue is it's throwing all kinds of
Errors so what it's saying here more or
less is that we haven't provided a token
for our session so we have no secret in
order to verify that this person is
correctly signed in with our application
and they didn't just create some bogus
session themselves so what we need to do
is inside ourv dolo we need to add a
next off secret here so this is going to
be called all capitals let's do next
oore secret and we will set this equal
to and then we're going to create one
now you can type in random characters
here and that would be fine but we want
to make sure that we have a certain
level of security here so open up your
terminal if you don't you can kill your
session if you're running it still from
before and let's generate that secret so
let's do open
SSL Rand base 64 and we want 32 and then
here you can see we generated a nice
little secret don't use mine just create
your own and then we have our next off
secret here so we should be good now
once you have that we can go ahead and
spin up our server again so let's do mpm
run
Dev so now back on our site if you get
any weirdness make sure you're shutting
down your server turning it back on you
can also try reloading this page and one
other thing that I have to do from time
to time when I'm playing around with
cookies sessions and things like that
hit control shift I if you're on Chrome
and here you can go to the application
Tab and under local storage session
storage and cookies you can clear those
out and that will sometimes help if it's
cash in and air anything like that
that's happened in the past I didn't
have it this time but just so you know
you can go through that
process obviously we don't have a
session right because we didn't have
that next off Secret in here so that
aired out so let's go ahead and try and
log in again you can do it with whatever
provider you would like I'm going to try
with my GitHub
again and you'll see that now we have a
log out so we do have a session here
which is awesome so if we go we don't
have any protected page is right now at
the moment so you can see our client
member our server session we can still
get to we can obviously still get to
public let's go ahead and try and log
out sign out and that goes back to the
home directory and I have my log in so
everything looks good but nothing is
protected so let's get into protecting
our routes we're going to do this in
three ways right now so I'm going to
quickly show you how to protect a server
side page a client side page and then
with our create user we're going to
protect it with with middleware for
right now and then we'll expand that to
protect it to make sure you're an admin
on top so let's go to it's really not
that difficult let's go to Our member
page first remember this is our member
server side session so let's take a look
here and we can set up a session so
we're going to need to check to see if
there is a session so we need to make
sure you're logged in so session equals
a wait get server session we'll do the
Auto Import so I'm going to tab here and
then I'm going to spit in our options
remember let's tab complete here so it
did those two Imports for us this also
needs to be a sync that looks great then
below here what happens if we don't have
a session so if we don't have a session
in this case so if there is no
session then let's do a
redirect and slide down so let's use the
one from next navigation make sure
you're looking at the redirect from next
navigation we'll import that and we can
redirect to SL API slof SL sign in
question call back Capital
URL equals SL member so what this is
going to do it's going to redirect us to
the login it's going to leave the call
back URL so if they do log in they'll
come back to this member page P so
that's going to be a nice look nice and
easy look so below here let's do just a
little more let's add a P tag and let's
say inside of here let's do curly
brackets so if we're here we do have a
session so let's say session question
mark. user question mark. email so we'll
spit out the email let's do that again
and this time let's say roll so remember
inside of our options on all these we're
setting up a role of some sort so for
our Google provider we are not setting
up one so that's going to cause an error
I'm going to minimize
this so here we're setting up a user
roll on our GitHub side of GitHub user
unless you're me Jake at Clarity coders
and then you're going to get an admin
roll on the Google one we didn't so
luckily we didn't try to O off with that
if you did I'm sorry
and we can paste in let user roll and
let's say Google user paste that down
there and now this should be working as
well we'll test out Google just to make
sure it works here down the road um but
for right now that should be good and on
the member page we should be protected
now let's try it so let's go to our
application you see we can go to public
if we try to go to member it asks us to
log in now make sure you're not already
logged in um in this case let's do
something different let's sign in with
Google just to make sure that works
since I did just find out that it
probably isn't for you guys pick a
Google account and you can see that our
member session it has my email address
and Google user there as well great so
that works let's go to our client
session now let's protect this it's
going to be a little different because
this is rendered the JavaScript is
rendered on the client session on my
client browser so we can't use the
server side get that we were using
before and I'll show you why before we
go there I'm going to copy these two P
tags let's go to our client member
page we can paste them below so this
will be if we have a session let's do
get server
session so if we do that you can see
that we get all kinds of crazy errors
well part of it's probably because I use
this let's control slash I'll just
comment this out for right now and then
let's navigate to that page we'll go to
create user and then I'm going to go
back to client member session so now if
we actually try to use get server
session to get our session so let's do
const session equals
await get server
session pass in our
options
you see we need to do an async
function so let's do async and we save
it we can uncomment
this save that and let's go to our
client member and you'll see we get an
error a sync AWA is not yet supported in
client components okay so we see our
problem there that's why we can't do it
the same so we can't do it in this
format which is fine we have other
options here so instead of of this so
let's do
import use
session and we're going to do
from next off SL
react so this is going to be how we grab
our session and then here we can grab
const we're going to set data equal to
session we're going to do equals use
session
parentheses curly
brackets required equals
true and then on
unauthenticated so what do we want to do
when we're unauthenticated we want to
redirect make sure you're using next
navigation again for your import
redirect and we're going to do something
very similar to what we did on the other
page so we're going to do slash API SLO
SL sign in question call back Capital
URL equals SL
client
member just like that so we're good and
if we control save this you'll notice
that we're getting new errors right Ed
session must be wrapped in a session
provider member so this is a little
complicated so the use session needs a
session
provider however the session provider
has to be a client component as well so
let's create a new file inside of our
components and we will call this o
provider.
JS and this is going to use
clients we are going to
import
session Provider from next o react so
you'll see it did the Auto Import for me
and we're going to do const off provider
equals we're going to pass in our
children then inside of here we're going
to return our session
provider
and don't worry
kids putting you right back in there we
need to export default off provider like
that so now we have our session provider
in a client component so we're good to
go there and we can go back to our
layout page and here's where we need to
wrap this bad boy to get our session on
the client side now remember this is
only if you need to do authentication on
the client side if you want to do it on
server side we're good
already so here let's utilize our
off provider this should be coming from
components
directory and then we're going to wrap
this around our children div
here like so now I don't have to wrap my
nav in it because I'm not using client
side on that you could certainly it
might even be better actually to wrap
this around your entire body just in
case we can do that I didn't need to for
mine but you might down the road so we
can wrap this off provider I believe
around the whole body like that and that
should function as well and then if you
have any client rendering here on the
nav side you can do that now again shy
away from client side rendering if you
can but if you have to um you can go
that route so now we have an off
provider here so our client member
should have a session now um and it
should you should need to be
authenticated so let's go back to this
let's just go back to Local Host you'll
see we got home uh we are logged in so
if you go to the member you can see that
we're still my email a Google user if I
go to client member now you'll see it
has the the
same both member server session and
client session are the same I'm both
authenticated form now if I log
out and I go to client member it is
protected now so that is good okay
what's middleware so if we don't want to
protect our Pages inside of each page we
can set up mid middleware on our project
and that will allow us to add
authentication rules in one spot that we
can easily find so let's create a new
file this is going to be on the same
location ASV dolo and let's call it
middleware
DJs we can do
export and then
default this is not what we're going to
stick with but we can do export default
from next off SL middleware so this
right now will protect everything so
everything on our page will be protected
then we can export
config equals let's do a matcher and
then we can pass in an array of URLs
that we want to test and here we can
protect create
user okay so right now we have it set up
so our create user should be protected
now you can see that's a lot easier than
adding it on the page or anything like
that and if we go here let's go ahead
and log in just with my Gmail so
remember I'm a regular user right now
okay now back back to our application
let's see if our create user is now
protected so you'll remember we're still
logged in so make sure you're
authenticated if you're not you can tell
because you have your printout here
let's go to create
user and you'll see that I can get to it
now I'm not on my admin account but we
haven't done that yet so it's just
protected from normies so let's go ahead
and log out sign out and now we don't
have any session so if I go to member it
tries to loog Lo me in if I go to create
user now it tries to log me in so that
is great so we've successfully protected
this with middleware however we still
are not protecting it from normal users
we only want this to be admin so let's
make that change let's go ahead and log
out and then we'll go back to our code
here so we're going to do some new
Imports so let's say with off I'll tab
here you can see my import that I'm
going to get with o above and let's also
do next
response and this is coming from next
server now we should have all of our
Imports We need oh my gosh I was on the
wrong
page don't do that so let's leave our
create user alone if you had that open I
apologize let's close out of all of
these I don't make that mistake again
so we're back on our
middleware page so on our middleware
page we're going to do those same two
Imports that we just did so we're going
to do with off and next response so
let's save that and you can see that we
got our two Imports done and then we're
going to make some changes to this file
I'm going to leave the matcher on here
because I only want this to apply to
that page I'm going to delete this out
and start fresh so I'm going to do X
Port
default with off now inside of this I
want to create a function for my
middleware and I'm going to get a
request when I visit a page and we can
console log out some information here
that might help you with future requests
or things that you want to do custom
wise so let's
console.log let's do our request. next
url. PATH name name so this will show
you what our path is so if you're trying
to do some logic here that may help and
then let's also use or at least log out
next request. next off. token. roll and
that could help us do some
troubleshooting as well now let's
actually Implement our logic so remember
again you can you can do any
customization you want here um anything
that makes sense with you but this is
what we're going to do to protect this
one create user page and make it only
admins so let's say if in here we want
to use our path name so let's copy this
we're going to say if request. paath
name so if we add other paths it might
not you know might have different logic
or whatever so let's say if it
starts
with create user and we want one other
test here and we want to make sure our
roll does not
equal admin then let's do curly brackets
let's save this just so it formats I'll
fix that okay so here's our logic here's
our if statement so we want to say if
we're going to the create user page and
you're not the admin so if you're not
the admin and you're trying to go there
let's just return next
response.
rewrite let's do a new
URL and we'll go to the denied
page
request.url so what we're going to do is
we're going to send them to that denied
page we created earlier now we could
send them to a login page but they're
already logged in this is for if they
don't have the correct role so they
shouldn't probably shouldn't be able to
just log into a different account so if
that is the case we're going to send
them to the deny page if not this will
continue on and they will be authorized
so let's add a comma here let's do call
backs colon curly brackets let's say
they are
authorized if they have a token
and that token is not null so we want to
make sure they have some sort of
a some sort of a token here we actually
need to wrap this in curly brackets as
well I believe I'm going to highlight
this wrap it in curly brackets and save
and you should have something that looks
like this so now we have our callback
function set up we have our middleware
all set up actually so we should be good
let's take a look let's go back to our
project we got all kinds of Errors let's
refresh So currently it does not look
like we're logged in let's go ahead and
log in with a non-admin account so if we
log in with our Google account in my
case yours might be different we go to
member you can see that our role is
Google user if we go to create user
you'll see that now we get a denied
let's log back out and this time I'm
going to log in with
GitHub you'll see that I do have an
admin session here which is great and if
I go to create user you can see that I
do in fact get to the create user page
so we should be good there so what we
have now is we have ooth provider set up
for GitHub and Google and we have
role-based authentication for both
server rendered pages and client
rendered Pages as well as ro-based
Authentication so we are good there now
you might be asking yourself well what
if I have a database already or what if
I want to create a database of users
that allows people to either use their
email or pick a username and a password
and set that up that isn't covered in a
lot of these tutorials because it's a
little more advanced and you have to
factor in things like validating email
or whatever it might be but I'm going to
show you how you can set that up connect
it to a database relatively quickly and
get it at least spun up and in place we
are not going to cover validating emails
so you need to keep that in the back of
your mind that this is more like a
username not necessarily an email
address I can pick Jake gmail.com even
though that is not my email address
let's go ahead and
kill our
terminal and then we'll do the remaining
Imports for this project so let's do
mpmi mongod
DB
mpmi
mongus and MPI
B
Crypt awesome now we got that set up
let's go ahead and sign up for a mongod
DB Atlas database now this is
free so if you have haven't used it
already go ahead and sign up for a
mongod DB Atlas account you should come
to a page like this you can
authenticate with very similar providers
to what we're setting up you can see how
popular they are so I'm going to go
ahead and log into
mine now if this is your first time you
might get some popups wanting to spin up
a database right away blah blah blah you
can skip all that hopefully eventually
you'll come to a page like this and what
we want to do is up in in at least right
now in the top left is to create a new
project we're going to call this next
off video tutorial in my case I'm the
project owner let's create our
project then once you get that created
we can create a deployment so let's do
create you can do the free
tier and then hit create you're going to
want to set up a username and password
here so on the next screen it gives you
an option to set up a username and
password note these down so inside your
EnV you can note these down I have admin
and then a password below so if I go
back to my
code inside. EnV let's just paste these
in here for right now let's say admin
and then our
password you'll want to add your current
IP address as well so we're going to add
that ah I forgot to hit create user Make
sure you hit create create
user and then finish and
close go to
overview and now you should have your
database set up so we're going to go
ahead and hit connect if you don't have
this there should be a connect button
somewhere or you might have to let
provisioning finish so once that's
finished you can hit connect we're going
to hit drivers and then we're going to
copy this string down here now back in
our code we're going to paste that
string in here pretty long you'll notice
it already has admin switch that out for
your username if you didn't use admin I
did so I'm not going to change it and
then we're going to copy our password
and paste in our password use your
password not mine obviously and then
here we're going to call this in all
caps mongod dbor
urii we're going to set that equal to
this
string if we slide to the back I'm going
to delete this back half so after the
question mark and I'm just going to call
this app DB like that that should be it
so our EnV is set up there that looks
good we can go ahead and close out of
that now let's create a new folder so in
parenthesis we're going to say
models inside of here we're going to
create a new file called capital u
user.js so we're going to find what a
user looks like in our system so we're
going to import
and curly brackets scheme a from
mongus and we're going to use mongus doc
connect process.
env. mongod
dbor mongus do promise with a capital P
equals
global.
promise then let's do
const user
schema equals new
schema do curly
brackets so let's just have a name and
that's a string an email and that's a
string a password you guessed it that's
a string after this curly bracket let's
do parentheses this is something I
always do with my models let's do
timestamps equals true this handles the
create at and updated at dates so it's
there for you if you ever need it and
then let's create our user model so cons
user equals mongus
models. user or so this is if it's
already defined or we use mongus
dood and create the user from our user
schema and let's export that so export
default
user spell default correct that looks
good okay so we got our model we got our
database set up now all we need to do is
create our API for creating a user and
then I'll show you how you can verify
against your existing users as well so
all we have left to do is to create the
front-end form that can submit a new
user then we'll create the API to add a
user to our database when someone
submits the form and then we'll add the
credentials provider and show you how to
validate that password let's create our
user form now this is a little unique
because we want this form to use client
side rendering because a form interacts
with the user with the JavaScript so you
might have validation on the front end
or whatever it might be
user form. jsx X inside of our
components
directory and then on this user form we
are going to use
client we're going to import use router
from next navigation not next router
this mixes me up sometimes so let's
change that to
navigation then we're going to import
react
and use state
from
react
const user form
equals recreate our function like
that and then at the bottom we'll export
I didn't use my short keys I wondered
what was weird about
this export user form see I can do it
guys all right then inside this we are
going to have a con router equals use
router we have a const form data this is
where we're going to store all of our
form data and we'll have a set form
data we'll set that equal to use
state with curly brackets inside so our
form data is just going to be an empty
object originally then we'll do const
error message so we're not going to do
much here
but I will check to see if that user
already that email is already in our
database and then we can send a
duplicate user type of error response
back so we have an error message and a
set error message equals use State this
will just be a blank string to start out
that makes
sense we need to handle our change in
our form and if you've done this before
it's pretty straightforward we're coding
it so it's it's pretty Dynamic doesn't
really matter what our form values
are I always do const value equals e.
target.
value copy that and I'll do
const name equals e. target. name and
then I will do set form
data I'm going to pass in the previous
state we
want another set of parentheses there
and then open curly brackets that looks
better so when we change our state so
this is anytime the state changes we're
going to say previous state we're going
to expand that so it's going to take
everything from the previous state
before and we're only going to overwrite
the one change that we're making so
whatever field on our form we're
changing and whatever value we're
setting it to we're going to override it
with and that's our handle change that's
it now from here we can do a
const handle
submit this equals an
async
function we're going to do e.
prevent
default we're going to reset our airor
message so if we previously had a airor
message we're going to set it back to
blank at the start of submitting our
form basically starting with a clean
slate we're going to get a response from
our own API that we haven't created yet
so we're going to do con response equals
a weit fetch then we're going to do API
slash users with a capital u remember
we're creating this in just a moment
parenthesis nope sorry comma and then
curly
brackets we'll do our method equals post
we're going to create a new user our
body is going to equal json.stringify
we're going to pass in the form data
just like
that we'll do content type and that
equals application
sljs okay almost done believe it or not
so we're going to check to see if our
response has an air so if our response
does not equal
okay then we want to get what the actual
error was we're going to pass back an
error here so we'll wait our
response.
Json and then we will set airor
message to whatever was in our
response. message and we'll show you how
we're going to set that in just a moment
so we're going to pass back some sort of
an error we're going to catch it here
and then we're going to set our error
message this is only for an error
remember we'll add an else so otherwise
we want to do router.
refresh and router. push and we'll push
to the root directory so this is just
going to send us back home and that's it
so pretty straightforward nothing crazy
here let's continue on and here we're
going to do a
return and let's do open and close let's
do form tags inside of those our form is
going to be pretty straightforward we're
going to do onsubmit and we've done all
the leg work now we're going to do
handle submit that we already created
our method equals
post and our class name just a few
Styles here going to equal
Flex Flex call let's save this just so
it
formats and that's my prettier extension
that helps me do that Flex Flex call Gap
three let's do a width of a half let's
do inside of this let's do H1 let's say
create new
user then below that we can start
creating our inputs don't worry they're
going to be very short let's do a label
and that label is going to be full name
then we'll have an input let's say input
our ID equals
name our name equals
name on
change equals handle change like
so let's make it required equals
true add another my closing tags there
and then I also need a
value which
equals form
data. name saving that so it formats
beautiful and last but not least let's
do a class name and we're going to copy
this so M2 BG of slate
400 rounded watch any of my videos I'm
not very good at styling so I just round
corners like crazy I'm going to copy the
label and the input paste it below this
one is going to be our email
so let's do email for an
ID email for the
name change the form data. email here as
well everything else looks good so that
should be good to
go let's copy all of it
again paste it
below let's do password ID of
password email form
data and this actually has a type of
password let's add that in these
probably should have a type as well
let's do a type equal to text for our
email and also for our
name okay that should be good to go
there the last piece is our submit
button so let's do
input the type equals submit MIT the
value will equal create
user and the class name let's stylist
just a tiny bit blue 300 with a
hover
of BG
blue
100 self-closing tag so we'll do slash
like
that slide over so you can see again so
we got our input button in the form we
got the form you might have wondered why
I wrap these all in closing tags
remember the whole return has to be
wrapped in some sort of tags and I'm
actually going to do something below the
form here so that's why I did that let's
do p tags and then inside of here let's
just print out our air message now this
will print out a blank string um when
there is no error but that's not a big
deal to me so we're going to leave that
there and then we'll change it to text
red 500 this looks good
think we're pretty good there should
have closed out of that terminal a long
time ago we got our user form created
let's create the API so inside this API
directory you see we have API off and
then next off inside of API so I'm going
to rightclick on API I'm going to create
a new folder and inside this new folder
I'm going to call it
users and inside of that user folder I'm
going to create cre a new file called
route. JS now we're only going to do one
function in here just to show you how a
post would work I'm going to pull in
next response from next server I'm going
to use our user model so I'm going to
pull that in as well you can see how it
does it up here with the at symbol tab
that now we got our user model and then
finally we have to do a encrypt before
we store it so we want to do import B
Crypt from
bcrypt now remember this you know we're
not validating an email so in my mind
this is like I run a company and I'm
inputting a user that I know has access
to that email address and that sort of
thing you wouldn't want to do this in
like a SAS application without
validating the email address because
someone could steal someone's email
address that they don't have access to
so let's export a
sync
function
post and we're going to get a
request let's do this all in a try catch
and for our catch let's
console.log our error that might help us
if we make a mistake I'm sure we won't
let's return um next response.
Json in here we're going to use that
message so we're going to use
message and then
err also return the error that looks
good got a comma here another set of
curly brackets let's also do a status of
500 if something goes
wrong okay that looks good now our Tri
block we're going to grab our body so
we're going to const body equals
await request. Json so we're going to
pull off the information we're going to
do const user data equals body.
form
data let's
confirm that our data exists the fields
that we need so we want to say
if we do not have user
data. email or if we do not have user
data. password
so if we don't have those fields we are
going to return a message so we want to
copy this we'll paste it in
here we're going to say a status of
400 and then our message can be let's
not send the error our message can be
all fields
are required so this shouldn't happen
because we're sending it with that one
form but down the road you change
something now you'll know if you're
getting information missing
information so let's check for duplicate
emails now so let's do a const we'll
call it duplicate equals a wait we're
going to use our model from above so
user find
one so we're going to see if we can find
any
email that has our you user data. email
do
lean and
execute now we can check so if there is
a
duplicate then we want to send another
response and we're doing kind of
meaningful responses here too right so
that's uh that's kind of a cool setup
that we have going we can do a status of
409 and we can
do
duplicate email now it's probably worth
noting here that we're also you might
want to be careful and make sure that
you're using um that you're checking all
your emails case insensitive so you
might want to lowercase all of them
before you add them to the database or
something like that because right now
you could have unique emails that just
have capitalization differences or
whatever it might be so keep that in
mind CL this that looks better so now
for here we know we don't have a
duplicate user we know we have all the
fields we need let's create our
hash password equals await
bcrypt
do and then we're going to pass in user
data.
password you can do as many salt rounds
as you want I always see 10 so you
probably shouldn't use 10 but that's
what what we'll use const and then user
data. password so now I'm overwriting
the plain text password with our new
hash password here so now our user data
contains our hash password we shouldn't
be saving plain text passwords and we
can await user.
create and we can pass in our user data
dang was longer than what I thought but
we got her
done so we create created the user data
let's copy a response we still want to
send a response our
message delete this can be user
created and our status can probably be
2011 awesome so this should be all we
need to create a
user so let's go ahead we've done a lot
let's go ahead and test that
make sure user gets created successfully
and then we can try and authenticate
with that user after we add the
credential provider which we haven't
done either so mpm run
Dev okay so we got our website here I
got to see who I'm logged in as I am
logged in as an admin so if you've added
this authentication and it's Ro based
you have to have admin now to go to
create user if you haven't done this you
can assign admin to someone else
else I'm going to go to create user this
is only admins duh because I didn't
update that so back on our create user
page instead of only admins let's render
our user form see it did the import for
me self closing
tags that is pretty who says I can't
style okay so let's create a new user
Bob
Bobby
bob.com password test of
course and create
user kind of looks like it worked Google
does not like my password it's been used
in a security breach so that's worth
noting um but it looks like it worked
okay so let's go back to our
database and I will click on
database now we didn't name our
collection so it's probably going to
give a test collection which is fine oh
no we did appdb we have a user you can
see we do have a user now awesome so we
have Bob Bobby Bob bob.com and a nice
hashed password so one step left here we
have to be able to authenticate with
Bobby now so let's log out we don't have
a credential provider at all so we can't
log in with a username and password
let's change that
so we're going to open up options let's
go ahead I'm going to shut down this
terminal just because I'll forget it's
running and then we'll be on the wrong
thing and close out all these just for
you
guys so below our Google provider let's
do
a credentials
provider yeah let's do a manual import
though let's copy this
one delete off the Google let's do
credentials provider just being careful
so I spell things correctly can cause
some weird errors and then this isn't
Google this is credentials with a lower
case
C okay so now we should have a
credentials provider to use down here
let's use that credentials provider
let's do parentheses and then curly
brackets so inside of here we need to
First tell our credentials provider what
they're going to use to log in so let's
call
it
credentials then let's set our
credentials equal to they're going to
enter an email could be a username could
be whatever you
want labels going to be this is just
like filling out the form honestly
they're just going to generate it for us
so we can label it
email we can say the type is
text and the
placeholder
is your
email put a coma below
that I'm going to copy
this change this to
password and we'll say we want a
password and then your password
and the type I bet we can put password
here too let's try that so we got a form
that it's going to create when we try to
log in with credentials provider of
email and password and then we have to
explicitly tell it how we're going to
authenticate so we could say
async
authorize you're going to get
credentials and then we'll do curly
brackets okay the one thing that I
recommend here right away is when you're
creating your authentication put it in a
try catch block because if you don't
nexo is going to spit you out a generic
error on the login form that would be
meant for the end user we don't want
that so at the end of this if we don't
return a user if at no point in this try
catch do we are we
successful at the very end we want to
return null which means means they're
not going to be
authenticated and then inside of here
inside of the air let's just do
console.log and then we'll do air for
that one so now we should get an air if
we mess up while we're creating it right
now that sort of thing so what we can do
is then we can use
const
found user so the first thing we need to
do is based on the email someone tries
to log in with we need to see if it
exists so we're going to do user which
we're going to import so I'm going to
Tab and it's going to do the import at
the
top see we got our
model so we're going to wait user. find
one we're going to pass in email or
we're going to look for an email that
has that is from
credentials.
email same as before we can do lean
Dot EXC like that so this should find
the user now if it doesn't so if we have
a found user we can move on to the next
step if it doesn't find a user it's
going to go down to this return null and
we're going to just give that air that
the credentials are incorrect we don't
want to give too much information you
know we don't want to say oh we couldn't
find that email address or whatever so
we're just going to say that the
credentials provided were not valid
regardless of if it's a bad email bad
password whatever so inside a found
user then for your sake our sake we can
say the
user exists you want to remove this
after you're done testing we do const
match so now we're going to test to see
if we have a good password so let's
bcrypt remember it's an encrypted
password and they're obviously going to
type the plain text one so we'll do
bcrypt do compare
we're going to compare credentials.
password
to the found user. password it looks
something like this bp. compare so this
is going to use our salt and compare it
we need to import that as well so we're
going to
import bcrypt
from
bcrypt we're real close now guys so if
we have a match so if match so if our
passwords do match then we can console.
log good pass again this is just for us
remove it after you're done and I also
want to delete from our found
user the dot password we don't really
need that anymore so I'm not even going
to keep it
around and then we can give our found
user a roll just like everyone else and
this equals just a reminder I know I've
overstated this but this is an
unverified email user and then only if
all that's successful we return our
found user that should be it guys
so that looks pretty
good let's open up our
terminal mpm
runev that looks good remember I'm not
logged in right now so and I don't want
to be because I'm just going to test my
credentials let's hope I can remember
this so it's Bob bob.com
lowercase and then test lowercase sign
in with
credentials you see it looks like it's
good so if I go to client member you can
see Bob bob.com unverified
email and then create user it's denied
I'm not an admin so that makes sense
awesome this looks great this is
functioning let me know if anything's
missing from this video in the comments
and I'll certainly make a followup
adjusting and giving you whatever you
would like to see remember inside this
authentication you can do whatever you
want so you could even hardcode these
somewhere these users somewhere if you
wanted to give out secret passwords to
your application or whatever it is is be
careful play around uh see what it's
like before you go a full production app
let me know in the comments any other
videos you want programming applications
anything you want to see that you
haven't seen around let me know I'll
create it if you haven't been to the
website check it out we have a cyborg
blog as well it has posts that are half
human half me we're creating articles
doing reviews thanks for watching and
until next time keep
coding